[MUSIC PLAYING]
EMILY FORTUNA: Hello,
I'm here with Nilay,
and she is one of the program
managers on the Flutter team.
And she also is
the key person who
is working on building
up our Flutter community.
Nilay, you have
done an amazing job
at building up the Flutter
community all around the world.
It's-- I am seriously impressed,
and I wanted to ask you
a little bit more about how
you got involved with that.
NILAY YENER: I actually
have a story about how
I started working with Flutter.
So I was working with
the developer communities
in another team at Google, and
then so with those communities,
they are trying to learn
about Google technologies.
They are running meetups.
They're asking for
some resources.
And all of a sudden,
the communities
started asking about Flutter.
Oh, we need some
speakers for Flutter.
Can we get some resources?
And I was like, oh,
what is that, Flutter?
I should look at that.
Basically, the community
attracted me about Flutter,
and I just looked into that.
And it was a great team.
I'm so happy being in this team.
EMILY FORTUNA: What all
do you take into account
to build a developer community?
You got a little bit into
that, but can you tell us more?
Do you have any advice?
NILAY YENER: Building
community is not an easy job,
but also it's not impossible.
So it's all about bringing
the right people together.
So if you want to build a
community around something,
you just have to
find the people that
is going to create the
foundation of your community.
They are the people
who is sharing
the same interest
on shared values,
and they are trying
to do something
with their technology.
This will be the
group of people they
are going to set the
tone of the community
and the standards
of the community.
EMILY FORTUNA: You work with
the Women Techmakers, I believe.
Can you tell us
a little bit more
about your
involvement with them?
NILAY YENER: I was running other
community events for everyone,
and then when we are
looking for speakers,
we got so many
requests, but very
little-- very less
requests from the women.
But when I did first Women
Techmakers Conference
in Istanbul, I got 50 women
speakers' submissions.
I was shocked.
Said, why these
women didn't submit
for the other conference?
And then I realized that
these kind of initiatives,
it is helping women to feel
more encouraged, more empowered,
so they are participating.
EMILY FORTUNA: Agreed.
Nilay, thank you so much
for talking with me.
This has been great.
[MUSIC PLAYING]